some of you i'm sure have heard me say
this that the real game being played
here
is that the better the best idea will
win
and so it isn't up to us to
promulgate our ideas and organize
funding and give fundraisers and hold
press conferences all we have to do is
articulate
and into this competing system of means
i really think we follow our fantasies
we are living out the fantasies
of people several generations ago people
who lived in a world of typhoid and
poverty and great restless proletarian
masses with very little hope of
advancing themselves and those people
said wouldn't it be great if we could
all live like kings and drink french
wines and
uh in our lives with art and
music and chocolate
and so basically we we now live in the
realized fantasy of the 19th century
bourgeoisie this is the hard part of it
and what we're asking of ourselves
is uh
you know to create a better fantasy a
better ideal and then the world will
flow toward it i thought it was
i want to tie this in with kathleen's
thing because i thought it was
wonderfully
poignant and cogent
that you address this issue of is it to
be the body perfected or is it to be the
body thrown away
and how try as we
we may try as we may to be
universal and catholic in our opinions
it seems like you're going to have to
come down one side with the other on
that
issue do we stay in the body and try to
solve the problems in 3d
the you know the momentum of
toxification of the planet the cleared
rainforest the extinguished species the
trash land
or
is it uh
is it for us to pass on
into
space colonies or the bowels of the
crystal structure of the earth or a
nearby hyperspatial fairy land
the issue being it's a pretty
fundamental one it's
how you think human right human nature
relates to the animal body we inherit
from the evolutionary process
is it monstrous
and mechanized and megalomanic
megalomanic to wish to transcend the
body and sail off in
a philosopher's stone kind of
hyperdimensional vehicle to our secret
destiny
thoroughly gnostic isn't it really
immoral
well thoroughly gnostic see what you
have here are two
great strains of thought
that have always been present in the
western dilemma and one is exactly what
i just said it's the view that we are
strangers here
we come from a better higher nobler
place
and uh as james joyce says in in
finnigan's way here in my cane which was
the red light district of dublin here in
my cane our earth we flop on the seamy
side
but up in the yent prospector you sprout
all your worth that woof your wings
so is it that view that we are
besmirched angels
and would just be so much more at home
far away from all this or is it that we
are creatures
of the earth
its custodians finding our completion
in a taoistic relationship of caring and
support to nature
and as i said at the beginning of this
little rap i don't think you can have it
both ways
you're going to have to this is one
issue where people are going to be able
to sort of finesse the differences away
and
i confess to be very conflicted on this
i feel very strongly this titanic
faustian
you know machines the size of manhattan
and the destiny lost among the stars
that kind of thing but it is of course
what gregory corso called flash gordon's
soup
real sustenance on the other hand
is uh this caring relationship to the
earth which recognizes uh
our origin
treats the earth as the bones of our
ancestors and comes to terms with it now
the question
aside from the purely abstract issue of
which of these
mutually exclusive positions is to be
recommended is the question can we
choose
the taoistic course
in other words
can
starting from today
with an atomic stockpile and leaking
nuclear plants and six billion people on
the planet is there any way to manage
this thing without making a pact with
the male ego with the engineering
mentality with the faustian demon that
promises stark light and all the rest of
it i don't really have an answer that's
why i keep looking for more exotic
escapes
[Music]
you